and then we're wondering about safety it
seems like once a year we have one of
these moments where we say is baseball
going to get to the point where they
have protective headgear for pitchers
Curt Schilling kind enough to join us on
short notice he a former all-star
pitcher three-time world champ shell
good morning how are you what's up have
you ever been hit like that with a
comebacker not in the head how close
close but it the key to the whole
scenario is what part of the head did he
get hit in the back of the head right
and at no point in a pitchers life's at
the back of his head every bead on plate
when he sort of it it's a combination of
a couple different things the first and
biggest thing is the lack of
minor-league innings these guys are
getting mm-hmm the PFP pitchers
fundamental practice it is such that
it's not a two-week spring training deal
for guys that that are serious about it
it's something you do all spring
training and kind of weekly during the
season you shouldn't your body and I
don't know what the medical science is
but I've talked to people who said your
body will prevent your face from being
hit for the most part as an athlete
almost every single time you know if
you're if you're finishing wrong if
you're unbalanced when you finish you
can't move like an athlete how many
times you see Greg Maddux get hit in the
head and probably never but nobody never
better position right right but if but
those are the things in the minor
leagues when you throw four or five
hundred innings in the minor leagues
those are the little things you're
allowed to to work on for a week or two
and them to understand them and to
understand building your position is the
difference between winning 17 to 20
games a year and it's also now becoming
every year you're right every year
somebody gets hit this is and I'm not
saying it's new because it happened in
the past but it wasn't ever like this
and obviously media is going to make it
bigger than it is I think but here's the
thing it's never going to happen you're
never ever going to get the players as
part of the cba to agree to doing that
to how many pitchers yeah I didn't know
even if you have a protective liner but
you know when you're
about wearing a face mask you know
there's no pitcher who's going to know
agree to do that and and even if they
tried it I would think with just the
violence of you know delivering a pitch
it's going to alter the mask that would
be on your face it would probably slide
right yeah yeah it's when you figure out
how fast the body is moving through a
delivery and the degrees of motion your
arms moving it's pretty it's pretty
magnificent and amazing but again at the
end of the day if you do your PF piece
you don't get hit in the face you're
gonna be hit in the body because there's
just some times where you can't get out
of the way I mean I've been hit all over
the body broke a hand broken elbow you
know all the other stuff but then the
hardest ever got hit didn't break
anything but the face you always get out
of the way of the face if you're in a
proper position you will not get hit in
the face I don't care how hard the balls
hit but you have these guys throwing
harder and coming off the bat faster all
right yeah well no I mean it's not there
are they throwing harder than Nolan Ryan
well I'm saying consistently I don't
know yeah you're you're right yes yeah
you're that is true that you have more
guys though yeah okay but again when you
look at combine the amount of
minor-league innings these guys are
pitching it's it's minuscule and that in
the minor leagues that's where you learn
how to pitch inside that's where you
learn how to drill somebody that's where
you learn how to field your position
that's where you learn how to defend
your position that's where you learn I
mean all of the little just like bunting
is out of you know these guys don't bunt
well anymore yeah they're the minor
leagues is the place where all of those
little things those nuances that make a
good big leaguer great happen and
they're not happening as much now do you
believe that Aroldis Chapman throws 105
yep yeah it's fun do you think that
Nolan Ryan actually threw faster than
ninety nine point six or whatever 101 or
whatever yeah yeah yeah like there are
men back then as a jugs gun to what we
have now right well and I don't know Bob
Feller used to motorcycle right yeah
he's but they had him at 96 miles an
hour I think yeah when he was like 13 I
think it was but I always thought I
never saw somebody throw harder than ol
Ryan and and granted Chapman throws hard
I just have a hard time thinking that
he's throwing it what miles per hour
faster well if you've watched first of
all I would tell you a hitter's I think
I'll tell you once you get above 95
there's not a whole lot of difference
it's just really fast what the easiest
way to tell is to watch the catcher's
glove watch the catcher's glove when
he's catching somebody throw 92 93 94
watch where it starts and how it moves
when or all this misses a spot watch how
quickly to catch your move how much
faster to catch rest and move and then
and then it's but the other thing is
that you know my Johnny Padres used to
tell me I'd say you know how hard am i
throwing you say the hitters will let
you know and this guy I don't it's fun
to I have my fantasy team so it's fun as
hell to watch but just he throw harder
than Randy Johnson does yeah yeah but
only for an inning Randy Randy 100 into
the 9th on pitch 135 I never understood
that though Kurt that it's almost as if
your body gets looser as you go on that
you can well you explain you know what
you're seeing it guys that throw this
harder max effort guys right I mean this
guy is going up every pitch that comes
out of his hand is is physically done at
110% whereas a guy life starter like RJ
or with good mechanics every pitch that
comes out of your hand is 75 to 85% and
then you know what runner on third I
need to dial it up I'm going from 96 to
101 because I've got something left in
the tank I mean that was you know I
always Billy Wagner and all those guys
was always amazing they do for an inning
I'm not belittling it said I always used
to get a reliever strapped like okay I
get it you threw 99 for 13 pitches how
about throwing 99 on pitch 120 I also
brought this story up a couple of days
ago remember 2002 you were at the
all-star game in an a-rod was gonna bat
third and you said I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna tell him I'm throwing it right
down the middle I'm throwing everything
right down the middle to see if you're
on fastball right yeah you told him
didn't you
yep and well I went to him be the day
before during BP and I said hey listen
if you come up tomorrow he's hitting
third I said if you come up to more
nobody's on I'm gonna throw you nothing
he's like what and I was like I've been
telling you if you come up tomorrow
anyone had a smirk on his face and I'm
like if you hit tomorrow with nobody on
I will throw you nothing but fastballs I
want to see what I can do against the
best hitter in the world when I'm
telling him what's coming he's like all
right kind of smiled and then so I went
fastball away at 97 fastball middle out
he fouled off broke his bat at 98 and
then I threw a fastball in 99 because of
your bat was over and I walked up to him
I walked up to change balls before the
event I said are you ready and he kind
of looked at me and smiled and laughed
and I was like all right let's do this
it was fun before I let you go
the Dodgers being careful with Clayton
Kershaw with the back I mean we talked
about Tommy John we talked about elbows
and you know arms shoulders yet when you
get to the back how dangerous can this
be for a show David Wright you know I
mean that that's the terrifying thing
and I think you're talking about and for
me you're talking about one of the
probably the 10 best pitchers of all
time if he stays healthy and continues
to go and even top 20 right now I've
always been a little concerned about his
health and he stayed very very help but
they hit in the back there Jim those
aren't unique those are common injuries
for pitchers and generally the back
comes from imbalance somewhere in the
lower body or if you have a pre-existing
vast situation but yeah I mean how do
you not play it carefully with him and
knowing him he'll be out there as soon
as he can be out there because he's he's
a badass he's a tough kid I I expected
you to be at the RNC were you an I
didn't get invited
I was ready man I was ready to stand up
there and scream wait you were in the
bullpen you you you were getting I was
hot yeah I got dry hump
I was ready man III I wanted I so badly
wanted to be out because I wanted to
speak well I always want to speak you
know I'm getting ready to roll into my
next career and and I thought this would
be a lot of fun yeah I was surprised you
know when they went Scott Baio that had
to hurt you a little bit yeah you know
what
except for the fact that that I'm
actually going out to be in Scotch the
tournament they had a they have a
charity tournament every year they lost
a child to to an illness and I talked to
him and and like I and I'm trying to
sound I'm like cut nice about but I feel
like I know what I'm talking about I'm
informed I'm well-read I tried to
understand he's very much the same way
he's not some actor just riffing like
Susan Sarandon or some other you know
Dunst who saying you know save the
whales it's he actually is informed and
so but yeah I was a little bit bummed
when I heard Tim Tebow at first I was
like oh wow man that sucks people's
getting a snap and I'm gonna sit here
but uh yeah I've I'm so glad everything
happened yesterday the way it did - yeah
you're not in the rotation man that's it
I know right well you know at my age I
guess inevitable hey thanks for joining
us so we appreciate a caramel all right
let's go Chili's the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience